good evening everybody and hello to
members my name is Moshe nationalists
acting for the council in this matter as
members as you can see we have no chair
or vice chair available tonight so I
need some nominations for tere please
and more nominations about I've asked
for any more nominations first that's
why I have today
okay Bobby better prepares oh come have
a second to please all those in favor
you can't cancel Richard can you take
the chair please
okay Thank You members for that vote of
confidence
my first job is to welcome our public
here this evening and thank you for for
joining and coming to watch and take
part I should stress that the the
meeting is a council committee meeting
it is not a public meeting there is
public participation and we're at the
appropriate points we'll have might you
up to the two chairs either side and
give you your opportunity to speak I
would be grateful if you could all
please turn your phone's off or at the
very least to to silent so that we can
carry on our business through anime okay
if you want to have a look at the
procedures for the for the meeting they
are on the inside front cover most of
you are looking at faces in that and the
in a seating area have been here before
so you should be familiar with our
procedure let me do some introductions
if I may to my far right we have amber
banks from committee services to on my
immediate right is Mason Nash has
already introduced himself as our
solicitor to my immediate left is Karen
take our planning manager Ellen Abbas on
her far left and then over in a corner
there we have James Hodgkins and Andrew
Watson okay so if we move straight to
our agenda in that case and our first
point is apologies please German we have
apologies from councillor Cargill for
whom councillor fielding is substituting
and apologies for counsel of Audrey for
who comes from a Crump is substituting
thank you very much welcome to you both
any disclosures of interests councillors
mm-hmm council lawn chair thank you I'm
the ward member for application 1701
three five four but erm I come here with
an open mind about this application and
I will take part okay thank you
Chancellor Bantz the last application as
he was speaking this Ward number and the
application in Temple Grafton I didn't
know the father some years ago but we'll
look at him down - okay lovely thank you
anymore for anymore
no good okay so let's move
through our first application which is
application number 1701 five three nine
rpm operating officers and about over to
you thank you chairman this application
is a reserved matters application for
nine apartments following the original
outline approval matters for
consideration our access appearance
landscaping layout and scale the
application site lies in the center of
Biddeford on Aven identified by the
black dot on the plan the site is
located on the main High Street with the
vacant health center currently occupying
the site it lies within a conservation
area with several listed buildings close
by which are shaded red on the plan to
the south of the site runs the river
Aven with the rear part lying in flood
zones 2 & 3 here we have the existing
site plan showing the footprint of the
current building on the site in relation
to the surrounding properties this is
the proposed site layout plan and
members will note that the building
would sit on roughly the same footprint
as the existing building albeit setback
from the pavement 22 parking spaces are
provided to the rear and side of the
site along with a communal landscaped
area here we have the proposed front and
rear elevations of the building with the
ridge height to be 7.5 meters high the
front elevation will be constructed of
brick with reconstituted stone Queens
along with fiber cement roof tiles and
PVC windows the rear elevation is to be
white rendered these are the proposed
side elevations to the east and west the
East elevation will have a mixture of
brick and render whilst the west
elevation will just be rendered the
ground floor plan shows floor for flats
to be provided the three-bedroom flat
will be to the front of the building and
have
to entrance doors onto the high street
in addition there is one to bed flaps
and to one bed flaps at ground floor at
first four or five flats will be
provided all of which will be two
bedroomed the flats to the rear will
benefit from balconies this is a
proposed street scene illustrating the
development in relation to the adjacent
buildings and showing the railings along
the front are now going to show some
photos of the site and its surroundings
here was standing to the front of the
site looking directly at the existing
vacant healthcare building the high
street runs along the front boundary we
are now further down the high street
looking up towards the applications
light which is on the right of the photo
members will note the historic building
line along the southern side of the high
street standing in the former
marketplace we're looking back towards
the site which is annotated on the photo
the adjacent pharmacy is to the left of
the application site this is the rear of
the existing building with the rear of
the pharmacy building in the background
of the photo on the right hand side
again standing to the rear we have the
existing building to the right and the
river even to the left on the right of
the photo in the background are the
rears of the residential properties
which front onto the high street there
are two updates to the application as
detailed within the update sheet
chairman the recommendation is to refuse
the application for the reason for the
reason set out on pages 11 to 12 of the
agenda thank you very much and members
just a very quick reminder that we are
looking at the reserved matters of an
have already approved outline
application in case you hadn't already
noticed I just thought I'd remind you of
that okay so let's move to our first
speakers please we have councillor
Knight and Elizabeth Douglas please come
forward
we have had the pleasure of your company
many times saying you know the drill and
three minutes will give you a 30-second
warning
whenever you're ready please feel free
to start don't get too close Thank You
Jenna good evening counselors from the
documents prepared by the offices it
would appear that we all fall in the
size and bulk of the building acceptable
the remaining issues are mainly in
respective appearance after careful
consideration at a parish council
meeting well attended by neighbors of
the property the parish counselor came
to the conclusion that the design was
well thought out and was sympathetic to
the conservation parameters of the high
street the developer has attempted to
incorporate many of the features evident
in the existing village center buildings
for example the old white lion building
at the west end of the road the
territory is of similar Georgian style
the east end of the row where this
development is sited is in effect the
start of the village center and setting
it back one meter this central feature
is enhanced and notably balances the
buildings on the opposite side of the
road which are also setback so did the
more attractive front gardens rarely
seen nowadays consideration should be
given to the existing open space between
this site and the chemist to the east
this will be used for car parking rear
gardens and access to the river frontage
this area were protected by railings for
purposes and for security and privacy
the proposal to extend these railings
along the front of the building is
considered to be an attractive feature
by the parish council
as a natural extension of the carpark
railings the materials being used are
similar or the same as those already
visible
the highest rate mainly brick or stone
and the developer has agreed to use
natural slate roofing tiles on first
sight the proposal use previously window
frames may cause concern but the
developer is choosing woodgrain finish
frames which are almost impossible to
distinguish from natural timber and have
the added adventure of advantage of
better thermal properties and low
maintenance the developer has also
agreed they had extra glazing creatures
to match as near as possible the local
windows styles all in all the
development it's a huge improvement on
the existing building which is now
falling into a state of disrepair
inviting unfortunately antisocial
behavior with ample carpark in for
residents and guests this development
offers one and two-bedroom dwellings
much needed in the parish the Parish
Council is a society space parish
counties ask this committee to grant
permission for this development to go
ahead in order to make these one and two
bedroom apartments available to the
local community I probably didn't need
to give you that warning tonight really
thank you very much
councillors do we have any questions
cancer carriage yeah just well thank you
you've addressed the railings and the
setback and the window frames and the
roof tiles very nicely the one last
thing she didn't mention was the littles
which we've been told are not
representative any comments ah what can
we say the lintels over the windows
we have their coins at the side the
looters that over the top which ones did
you mean according to the bundles I
think in both
I can ask officers we will ask doctors
manizer any any other questions no more
questions no wonderful in that case
thank you very much I will call for our
second set of speakers in that case
please and I believe our applicants mr.
and mrs. Prosser from Prosser hands so
welcome this evening I'm not sure we
have seen each other before so there's a
button in the middle of your microphone
that will turn it on and please make
sure it is on while you speak and you
will have three minutes I'll give you a
30-second warning whenever you're ready
please start okay we've spent a lot of
time researching the existing buildings
in Bedford High Street have incorporated
these features into our design features
such as stone window sills and heads
which can be found on no less than 23 of
the existing properties along the high
street also stone coins that can be seen
on number four and number 57 High Street
the Regency styling of our design is a
very close match to the existing Estate
Agents building which is only two doors
up on the High Street and the large
Regency style building located adjacent
to the historic bridge at the other end
of the high street sash windows and
low-rise slate pitched roofing are all
characteristic of buildings found on the
high street the current day uPVC sash
windows which are proposed to use are
far superior to timber in the way of
acoustic and thermal properties and
maintenance we've got I think we've
actually given you some information on
the windows we're going to use as well
as sliding sash windows with the wood
grain finish before this meeting we did
drop those off yesterday we only build
interesting in attractive buildings with
plenty of detailing and carefully
selected materials the facing bricks
we're going to use will be a reclaimed
looking brick which will give an
instantly aged appearance to the
building our design appears to have the
support of the local residents and the
parish council most of whom I have met
face to face and had discussions with
them regarding the new building look and
access Arrangements around the back
car parking this is significant support
for the proposals considering these
people live and breathe the local area
we strongly believe that the building
should be set back from the existing
pavement for a number of reasons the
building will be a prominent and
standalone building which is detached
from the existing terrace of cottages
and the pharmacy shop by considerable
margins it forms the transition between
the wide open village square end of the
high street and the narrow terraced end
of the high street towards the traffic
lights setback with traditional railings
and landscaping to the front will
improve the street scene whilst creating
a more pedestrian friendly environment
the houses directly opposite the the
site have also been set back two metres
from the pavement with beautifully
manicured front Gardens which create a
nice feature to the high street finally
we would like to point out that the
building was purchased as a development
site without line planning granted it is
empty
partly derelict and is rapidly becoming
an eyesore that could attract the wrong
attention if left any longer I just want
to reiterate the fact that it should be
away from the pavement for safety
reasons you know worst case scenario
people coming out of their apartments
child and a bike coming down the
pavement what do they do go into the
road
it's a busy road tractors buses cars so
and you know most towns now have got
pedestrianised 818 and that's what we
want to do create a safe environment for
the high street okay thank you very much
nice to spawn three minutes councilors
any questions can civilian
accounts failing to mute any microphone
on PC it refers to the paperwork about
flooding at the rear of the building
are you taking any precautions of case
of flooding or high water the the car
park is at the flood zone we've done a
flood risk assessment for the whole
development the building has never
flooded it's 300 millimeters above the
one in thousand
storm levels but it's true the carpark
does flood obviously all of the new
residents will contact the the NRL that
their local authorities so they have an
early warning system in place to move
their cars to higher ground if if there
are warnings are flooding between this
railing and the building 1 meter the
building setback 1 meter on the drawings
canceling looking at the the roofline of
the proper of the your proposed property
are you doing a ridge either side coming
in over the dam pipes or is that just
gonna be one solid roof line where the
the EES detail is it's quite a large
overhang it's a typical Georgian soffit
to it the the soffits probably about
three or four hundred millimeters you
can just see it on the ends of the
building there so it does overhang a
long way then it's got those feature
timber brackets a sort of George and
Regency style brackets that support that
eaves and gutter detail just a straight
flat well straight one pitch level a bit
more feature that it's got a very low
rise pitch roof is about 16 17 degrees
and then obviously at the very top of
its a flat roof is quite a large flat
roof above that but what you can see
from the street is that is a low-rise
slate roof though much like the estate
agents building two doors up is very
low-rise typical Georgian roof kurta
excellent thank you very much if there
are no further questions from our no
okay in that case thank you very much we
will now seek to move to our ward member
mr. Pemberton Castle Emerson are you
here no okay in that case and we will
move straight into and points of
clarification and technical details does
anyone have any points of clarification
or technical questions no marvelousness
moved to debate who would like to start
cancer Jones
I think two points that are really
important for committee to remember is
that it's within the conservation area
and there are listed buildings in the
vicinity so we have to so it's gotta be
careful in our deliberations that it's
not just a question of I'll do we like
the design and is it okay we have to
take very special care these are very
very important areas in the district my
second point is that I really don't like
the argument about oh it's a huge
improvement on what's there that's in my
view of limited relevance because what
we're not looking to do is say oh well
somebody allowed a bad job to go up and
therefore and if you know on that basis
anything would be better no we want to
get the absolute best we can get in this
position because it's an important area
within the district looking at all the
things that the conservation areas
referred to personally I think that they
are they are valid and they've got a lot
of weight I don't think the gray roof
slate looking at what's around is
particularly the type of material that
proposes particularly in keeping I don't
think you PVC window is in any way
appropriate I know it's been said that
wood grain finish looks similar I just
personally don't agree I think it's
always quite apparent that wood grain
finishes plastic
I think the coins I understand the point
that there's some use of its in other
areas and parts but it's not a key
feature and I think because of the size
of this building and the scale of it
what what it looks like is going to make
a difference and that's going to be
quite a big feature putting this big
Georgian Regency type building with
railings and coins and I don't think it
is in keeping with that marketplace sort
of smaller feel and for me I think the
conservation offices you know whose
opinion I think we should give quite a
lot of weight to the expert we rely on
to make these judgments makes a good and
strong argument in the written report
Thank You councillor bonds don't always
agree there gas
over them in this respect has on their
Biddeford high street quite well it is a
show she's building but it was built for
a purpose and many many years ago before
we are planning this is a bit of an
improvement I don't like the Royals in
the front of the distance don't see all
the rubbish bins in there they're
bidding daily rattles on that now Street
so unfortunately I would go along with
the opposite of this don't anything
collaborative of those that but is it
that's an official proposal is it okay
and seconded by Councillor jars and SS
further debate we can move to the vote
in that case no further debate okay so
we are now looking to have a vote on the
refusal in line words offer us at in
line with officers recommendation which
can have a show of hands before the
refusal against abstaining
Marvis thank you very much okay so the
committee resolves therefore to refuse
application 1701 539 r.e.m in line with
the officers recommendation okay thank
you and we're gonna have a quick change
of officer so our next application is
application 1701 nine to nine ful our
presenting officer is James Hodgkins
James we'll just have a minute while you
find your stuff and then there's over to
you
okay so members Casavant
remember we said james is about to give
us a presentation on this application
oh gee James Thank You Jay and so this
application seeks a full Planning
Commission for the construction of two
semi-detached dwellings and a number of
associated works including the provision
of a new access as identified by the
black dots the application site is
located within the village of Studley
here you can see it forms part of the
the dwelling actually known as 32 cooks
Lane which is actually outlined in red
and that shows the entire site there so
it's predominantly a residential area
however they're steadily high school
here located to the east and some
community facilities located to the
north
just looking directly at some of the
plans this is the proposed block plan
adjacent to the existing block plan so
it just shows the comparison which shows
the two proposed units here sitting in
front of the existing dwelling just
there this is the proposed elevations of
how the two new dwellings will appear
and front side and rear elevations their
standard semi-detached property split
down the middle here and equally the
same we've got some floor plans the gain
very much mirror one another in terms
their design 3-bedroom properties with
lungs and kitchen dining space it
ground-floor so this is the proposed
street scene and how the obviously do
you the dwellings will appear so we have
the adjoining neighbors to the left and
do a neighbor to the right and the
existing property stuck behind to that
you can see this this property there
just start in front which is the two and
just as a bit of context and a bit of
comparison again this is the existing
street scene and the existing floor
plans of the of the detached property
just want to move on some photographs
you can get a context to the site this
is the existing dwelling as is as it
remains in present and still
predominantly roughly where roughly
where one of the units would go this is
obviously just step back then on the
other side of a crooks Lane just
into the site just to get comparison at
the street scene this is the one access
points that six existing largely looking
at exactly where the proposed dwellings
would be and this is the existing access
that will remain solely then there's the
the sole access re to the existing
bloody just just again just take a idea
the street scene
these are predominately the residential
pattern of the this size the road here
and we're looking towards a site which
is actually behind this tree line area
and I lost a lot of the vegetation will
remain but some of that will be
substantially cut back as well the
offered the applications actually
recommended for refusal as outlined on
page 25 if the report thank you okay
there is one very brief update in the
update sheet as well which I will draw
members attention to I think it's just a
typing error okay so let's move to our
first speaker in that case which is
councillor Paul Bremen from the parish
council sadly parish council welcome
councillor Beeman you've definitely been
here before
thank you sharing more than one occasion
so you look in the last one we had okay
so you got sorry not when it's gonna be
thirty second one Thank You chairman
cancellous approach council are quite
keen to get this application approved if
you are aware of a parish plan we are
desperate for family homes this plan is
to provide to family homes for the
applicants family it is a site that will
take these properties quite comfortably
the applicant if it was a money-making
exercise could have bought flats on
there with no amenity space of no
parking that has been permitted by
inspectors elsewhere in sadly so that is
something I think needs to be taken into
consideration that this is is for the
applicants family and we think it's
something that actually improves the
street scene they lay down down what you
saw in the picture are overbearing that
they come over the footpath and they
cause problems with kids walking to
school which is 50 yards down the road
it is
we'll make this fixing so much better I
think some of the positives in this are
is that it is in a sustainable location
there will be significant improvements
to the access to the site at moment
there are two driveways in and out which
can be used at all times I know there is
any one property there but it can be
used in an a by both that one will
actually be shut and will form part of
the the new development which will make
it much better the parking is at the
rear the design fits in with all the
other properties in the area it just
actually fits in quite nicely
I think one of the concerns officers
have is the overlooking of the gardens
but if you actually look at the plans
the gardens are that obviously the back
of the properties but can only be seen
by the bedroom windows of the property
that is there that is something that's
happened in nearly every every area
wherever you go if you look at the back
wind even seen to you next-door
neighbor's garden this is not really any
different to any of those and it will be
family members that will be living there
it is not for strange as it did for
family members and we think that in
itself is justification for this to go
through we are desperate to try and find
these properties in the village this is
one of the few sites where we can get
family homes in in a sustainable
location and we would ask that you
actually do approve this one wonderful
thank you very much council Vania
members do we have any questions
councillor crop thank you nice to see it
question is endorsed by the parish
council on cats of 10 cows are we are we
are very fortunate in being surrounded
by green belt but the problem that
creates is that we are very limited as
to where we can get as is and where we
can infill we are quite keen to build on
brownfield sites and
wooden Foresight's come up this is one
of those windfall sites where we can
actually get two homes in without taking
Greenbelt and without taking a useful
garden space this is after all it's it's
almost scrub land it's not used by the
president and the present occupants
there it is in front of the property
their main garden is at the rear so it
is in a location where we will be happy
supporting development okay any other
questions
so filling entrances to the houses
affect the school it will actually
improve parking because at the moment
there's two driveways there one of those
will go when this development is is
constructed so therefore the there will
be an extra parking space there that
residents can actually use the school
traffic can use and it is a first thing
in the morning lasting at night so yeah
I think you answer the question thank
you
I have any other questions I can serve
answer you a question if you have can
you know okay Margaret in that case
council women's thank you very much
thank you thank you we'll move to our
next weekend if we may please who is
Gary Phillips the agents for the
application Gary welcome I think we've
met before you know the drill three
minutes I'll give you a 30-second
warning whenever you'll read a much mr.
chair nice timing
this application has been designed so
that the property is very similar to the
scale of linear development along crooks
lane so effectively it's a three to
three-bedroom dwellings has been advised
and there's no quit there's been no
effectively objections from the
technical sort of consultations they've
been undertaken with the property
there's been one objection from somebody
outside of crooks Lane that we haven't
been out
locate and the objection in relation to
the property itself from the officer
seems to be in relation to the
overlooking from the existing house and
the fact that we can't achieve 10 meters
to the back garden fence line
we've actually got no overlooking
directly from the property to the
existing house but by relocating the
gardens and have actually sent a revised
location site plan to the planning
officer we could actually relocate the
gardens to the side of the second plot
which is effectively the one closest to
32a and we are also able to provide at
least 70 metres square of amenity area
outside of that 10 metre zone which is
referred to as the main objection reason
the in officer's comments the main house
itself maintains a real garden which has
250 meter square of amenity area the
houses at the moment can potentially
achieve a hundred square meters each of
immunity so well within Council criteria
and would comment that in the report
itself it does color sorry it does
comment that cs9 policy is complied with
so as I say we can amend the scheme and
improve things and lastly we have also
identified that adjacent to unit 3
there's a commercial development shown
on the plan of two units two and three
we do actually own or our applicant owns
the land the other side of the red line
so we have the opportunity to actually
extend the fence line to improve amenity
closer to 30 B thank you very much thank
you very much members do we have any
questions cancer fielding council
feeling first ones council fairly
you said the the red lines not along the
boundary of the properties accurate did
it go to sort of towards the garage more
yes effectively this has come to light
in the last week or so so where it says
crooks Lane on the key and that line
follows its way all the way through to
the commercial unit unit three we do
actually own that land as well so in
theory the amenity space could be
increased further which would take the
garden space for plot one outside of the
the area of concern and as I say plot
two has the potential to have side
garden obviously if you are minded to
allow offices sorry sorry mister I'm
gonna cross you there just I need to
remind members that what we're
considering is what is in front of us
now we don't have the facility to change
the red line or change the design or
anything like that it's what is in front
of us now
okay counts the barns you had a question
the implication when the Parish whether
if they're just family home to sell
they're not for your family yes that's
right they've the applicant has for
proper children and the intention is for
those children to live in the homes
that's great thank you members do we
have any other questions for our agent
no miss Phillips thank you very much
we will now seek a ward member we do
have cancer right welcome
that's right welcome you've done this
before obviously you know you have five
minutes I will give you a 30 second
please when you're ready
looking at this application on the
surface it seems very reasonable
it would figure to fit the criterion our
guidance but if you read the report
carefully and I do believe that the
officer has argued the case very well so
refusals pointing out the deficiencies
and balancing them against both the
local and national guidance therefore
when this application is examined in
detail you'll realize the impact on
residential amenity it should be
accepted but this should always provided
in any house satisfactory
living environment for future occupiers
of the development that should be a
consideration this is supported by
criterion b8 of policy CS 9 and it is
reproduced in your agenda and it makes
it quite clear again in detail of the
reader in the detail the relationship
between the host property and the
proposed dwellings issues are raised
most notably a separation of distance
which is considered reasonable generally
is 21 meters to be maintained between
the front and rear elevation of
neighboring properties in these
proposals there is only a distance of 14
meters further deficiencies are
identified in this report overlooking
overshadowing but it's all detailed
there this in my view is density and
inappropriate development and surely
when you look at this and measure it
carefully it has to be over development
compounding this is insufficient
immediately value of the proposed
dwellings the gardens are an example of
the MP mpps directs us to always seek a
good standard of amenity for all
existing and future occupant of land and
building and quite honestly personal
issues as far as I'm aware is not a
planning reason unless exchanged I don't
know but I've never seen personal
reasons as a planning issue and also it
was pointed out in the previous
discussion about the plan but something
is better than nothing
and I actually think that's a value that
the committee should hang on to we want
the best and the most appropriate not as
something better than nothing attitude
so really I am asking to support the
recommendation that has come from the
officer of refusal because I do believe
it's a very just and well argued case
and if you carefully read you'll see
that the details are all there in the
report itself cancer may thanks for that
members do we have any questions for
cancer right no Morris in that case
thank you very much we will move in that
occasion to our technical discussion
members do we have any technical
counsel Vance first any self counsel or
named at all if we were to approve them
they wouldn't have a name to them they
both took up the family yeah they've
been assessed as open market clients
there's no specific tie to tying them to
32 is that the proposal is for two
semi-detached dwellings I understand the
submission but they are open market
though yes okay councillor Thank You
chair well it is actually supplemental
to what castle abarnes is asking is it
possible to condition these four to link
them to the main house
I'm goods chair the application isn't
for local needs house these are two
ended the application ease as the
officer said open market houses and I
would lead you to determine them on that
basis okay any further technical
questions no in that case let's move to
debate council Thank You chair um I'm
I'm wholly agreement this is a very good
report by the officer um my view on this
is I think this is before us in a form
that I can't accept I do agree with the
parish council that these are perfectly
acceptable houses and required in
Studley but I think the amenity can be
improved as the applicant has already
said and I would like to propose that we
go with his office as a recommendation
to refuse his application but give some
encouragement to the applicant or they
come back with a design layouts that
provides amenity to the right hand side
of the new rock and to the rear and as
we've heard there is possibly a little
additional bit of land on the left-hand
side if that could be incorporated then
I would have no problem in approving
this Thank You councillor Giles then
councillor balance I'm happy to second
that proposal I think Council to write
some things up very well the report very
specifically identifies the deficiencies
in that separation distance between the
runs and front and rear elevations of
the neighboring and host property which
is significant first floor window to
garden neighboring relationship should
be 10 meters it's three meters
substantial overlooking and overshadow
into amenity space there's no argument
that with the principle of development
here no argument that this would be an
important addition to the area but it
can be done better and I think when we
put all of those difficulties
cumulatively it clearly isn't the right
the right proposal and designed in the
right way so I'm happy to the second
proposal
thank you very much Chancellor Bantz mr.
Jarry materiality there
and still need two areas but it isn't
right okay
well shorten to the point thank you okay
so we have we have a proposer and under
seconder and so the proposal is to
refuse in line with his officers
recommendation can I have a show of
hands to support the refusal fabulous
okay thank you very much the committee
of therefore resolves to refuse
application 1701 nine to nine ful in
line with the power recommendation James
thank you very much we will now move to
our next item which is item 1700 eight
five six ful our presenting officer is
Andrew Watson I will let you get seated
before we begin
I can't say country over to you when
you're ready this is an application for
the rectum agricultural storage building
on one giant temple Grafton on the site
I was yes yeah the site's identified by
the black dot the application site is in
the countryside north of Temple Grafton
mission area designated as part of the
album special an escape area the to dr.
green lines you can see north love the
site of footpaths and the red blob is
where the building is roughly located
and moving on they've got an area of
feel as you can see the sites the
building to the north the red blob is a
conversation very equitable to don't
want to Dumpty's underway and the
immediate adjacent to left at the red
spot we have got to have standing there
for a stable which is already been
approved move location plan against rim
pretty much the same and a better site
location plan will have got the stable
building the bottom left-hand corner
with a small building next to it and the
roadway you can see from the access
that's the building itself which is
about a four meters by four point nine
meters the right being of 3.15 to the
meet the ridge
and 2.2 meters approximately to the
eaves the material moustache laughs
timber with a metal profile roof that
building is a stable block there's a
safe not been built that's what we have
approved and miss appeared to watch the
similar Heights that's at that building
as well in terms of got a couple of
photographs that's looking from the
entrance the building you can the
proposed storage building just on the
Left bear in front of the trees in
across the middle of the photograph
refer where that Bush is in the middle
that's where it's going and that's
looking from the road itself the edge
row is the back of the bottom of the
site and just beyond the on the left
there I can't quite see is the hard base
for the stable building the building BIA
but the builders this application gilded
just beyond that boundary that's it
so in terms of an update we have
proposed are proposing a new con another
con dition
to restrict it to agricultural storage
only Andrew thank you very much for that
before we go to our first speak and i
just remind everyone to make sure their
phones are either off or unsilent we've
have heard a couple go off or a teen
it's slightly distracting thank you very
much okay so we our first speaker is in
fact the applicant on this now I'm gonna
turn to your surname Patricia is it
enough come out okay
please come forward
okay so you've obviously seen that how
things work you have three minutes ice
okay we do only have yourself to
register to speak I assume your as a
supporter in that case you've three
minutes when you're ready and we'll give
you a 30 second one thank you so we are
the owners of this agricultural land of
10 acres the land is used for grazing
and the cropping of hay proximately 200
bales annually near the past this was
done by local farmer using his own
equipment work is now nearly finished
for the conversion of a large portal
frame barn to a house where we will live
and we also have planning permission as
you've seen for a small staple for our
rescue donkey and horse
hence the requirement for the hay we
will now manage the land ourselves and
the proposed agricultural building is
necessary to store the relevant
equipment for the maintenance and
farming of the land more specifically it
will be used for the storage of a quad
bike flail mower head cutter strimmer
chain hoist sprayer grass leader space
stakes
spades rakes Forks and fencing materials
there are no other agricultural
buildings on the holding the Parish
Council is unhappy that we have
converted the only barn on the land to a
house
however this conversion is allowed by
permitted development rights and is
supported by government in order to
increase the stock of houses in rural
areas the former barn was empty for many
years and much too large for our
agricultural needs all that is needed is
a small secure agricultural store it's
just a shed in fact and that's what's
proposed here at 16 foot by 16 foot it's
seven times smaller than the formal barn
and would be barely visible
barely visible to the public we're
therefore kindly ask you to support the
officer recommendation and grant
planning permission thank you for your
consideration
you very much members to have any
questions I think well I think what
we'll do is ask the officer to clarify
because we don't know for sure
members any other questions no case
thank you very much okay so our final
speaker cancer Adams
would you like to come forward how much
counsel haven't registered to speak okay
okay I tell you what counsel Adams can
you come forward and do your bit and
while you do that I will just confer
with my committee services
representative
say what what we'll do is and is going
to come and speak to yourself searches
to confirm where and when your your
intent to speak was registered whoa
while we do that and I'm going to go
upstairs and check will listen to
yourself councillor Adams and then we'll
have a idea of where we are so cancer
Adam is when you're ready you have five
minutes Thank You mr. chairman five
minutes as you've heard the redundant
sorry conscious terminal hearing aids as
you've heard the redundant bomb has
already been converted into a dwelling
on this site together with permission
for a stable block my objection is there
is already a substantial development on
this site without this additional
building the site using open countryside
closes the footpaths
I've seen in the Auden special landscape
area that's all I have to say mr. Chanin
okay thank you very much members do we
have any questions
councillor Crump
can select run now
yeah just one pretty small question the
applicants gave the impression it was to
have a secure building and because the
amount of materials equipment repairs
now are there any issues regarding rural
crime okay
and any other questions from members
canceling if you have see what hang on I
said I think this is what we're selling
questions for the ward member because of
what will walk member no and if the
homeowner doesn't know we can ask and
technical okay we'll come back to that
in technical I think that's the right
time to do that
members unless there are any other
questions which I don't believe there
are what we're going to do will adjourn
for two minutes just while we wait for
him to come back down again and then we
will come back in and and proceed okay
so if you want to grab a quick drink cup
of coffee come for break now's the time
two minutes
let's let's bring this back to order
please
okay so members and just so you are
aware we now have the email from from
the Clark at the temp proper - Council
specifically it does in this detail the
field view which is the application
we're going to be looking at later on it
does appear to be a genuine mistake so I
proposed to allow Cancer Care is it
Colonel cans keys
sorry counts the keys I propose that we
allow you to speak you have indicated
it's gonna be brief so that would be
helpful so if you wanna come forward and
make your point yeah you will have three
minutes and I'll give you a 30-second
warning so as soon as you're settled and
ready you can start Thank You chairman
Eric only to allow me to speak I think
it's probably my error that but some and
way it will be brief I just wanted to
explain to members the sensitivity
around this area of tempo grafton the
members will be well aware that there
have been long-standing planning issues
up at the top of Croft Lane north of
Temple Grafton
been going on for years and it has
caused a certain amount of concentration
within the village and we have been told
by villagers when we put out a an
informal housing needs survey three or
four years ago that their preference for
development would be within the village
boundary infill development and not
development particularly long Croft Lane
where it is the east of Croft Lane is
the special landscape area we hope to
update our parish plan which is now ten
years old to sort of reinforce the views
that came out in this housing needs
survey and I'm sure they will but in
order to be consistent the parish
council took the view that it would not
support development outside the village
boundary and that's what we're doing
here we have objected to other
developments in various parts of the
parish and not let's say just in just
close to the village either and I just
wanted to make it clear that it's a sort
of objection in principle as opposed to
an objection to a store for agricultural
tools which are arguably needed in this
case however I do struggle somewhat with
the sort of perverse logic of declaring
redundant to barn for agricultural
storage converting into a house then
suddenly we need agricultural storage
again it's I can't quite get my head
around that but that's all I really want
to say and just to reiterate it is a
question of being consistent with our
planning applications or our response to
them that we have objected in this case
thank you fantastic thank you very much
that clarity is helpful members cancer
company hello cancer peas and I thought
I heard you right you mentioned it was I
think that was the price you used about
building in off Croft line yet when I'm
looking here
the only third-party response part from
yourselves was the CPR II so I'm just
can't see the link between conservation
and lack of response on third parties I
also did say this come back in many
years since the [ __ ] site was proposed
and that is literally a field and a half
away from this site and that's where the
consummation comes from so we allow
don't object to development on this side
and maybe it gives the green light to or
precedent to development elsewhere on
Croft Lake which is outside boundary
okay thank you very much and cancer ban
sir do you have a hand up I did most of
your speech appeared to be on a bond
that became a house which I believe has
got planning permission in area is that
correct I don't think that's relevant to
be honest that's not relevant we're not
here to discuss something that's
happened in the past and it's got
permission it members any further
questions no excuse thank you very much
we'll see shortly okay members say we
will open up now to technical we did
have a technical question on the
distance from the road I don't know if
you're able to answer that best second
court please it's just over 40 meters
from the edge of a carrot or a the edge
of the proposed building
thank you counts the carriage I really
like hearing for the parish councils a
very useful you go ride the parish
houses point is very apt I think this is
just a shed which is you know obviously
needed in this situation however maybe
you can refresh my mind on the actual
wording of some of these policies the
cou cues because I thought there would
be some restrictions on future bond
applications if you use this cou Q to
get rid of a barn which seems to be the
consternation of the parish council and
and myself actually sure if I can
clarify the class q applications relate
solely to the building so it's an
assessment of the gabon and its
suitability for a conversion it doesn't
take into account any future impact any
impacts in terms of where you then we
relocate any equipment to so you can
have this in our
okay thank you okay counselors any
further questions in this technical
section no marvelous let's move to
debates councillor Giles first then
council feeling I mean parish councillor
in cap councillor desire to protect
temple Grafton and its surroundings is
abnormal I'm not sure a sort of a
standing principle in objection is
particularly helpful because the whole
purpose is to look at each application
on its merits and this is a four meter
squared building which is shielded and
been placed next to another building so
it's going to be fairly busy visible so
it doesn't really seem like the
application to sort of make a point over
I do thought when I read the papers like
I can understand this sort of argument
about there was an agricultural building
and why do you then convert that to say
that you then need another agricultural
building but there's clearly a
difference here because the kind of
agricultural undertaking that would have
been needed to come out of a building of
a huge size is very different from
saying basically I need a shed to store
it a bit of equipment to service the
land to that building in a kind of a
semi residential horse donkey storage
capacity so yeah that I just don't see
any reason whatsoever for not granting
this application council feeling on page
37 of the the plan it showed the
building being in the top right hand
corner and I think that was next to the
footpath which really would have stood
out whereas this one as councillor Giles
has just said he's tucked in behind the
stables which adds extra security to it
a lot of the equipment being stored in
there the local police will state as
people have like touches and they have a
tenancy to disappear and I feel for the
sake of security and storage of
equipment I can't see any problems with
it and this seems to be quite a lot of
security in and around that field anyway
which would help to protect it
Thank You counselor feeling before we
move I've got counselor buns and
carriage Shane before we move to you
guys I'm just going to ask for clarity
because on facial 87 we do have in one
place and I was thinking we've got in
front of me here it's in another which
one is it well it first came in he
wasn't wasn't the top and it sparked the
negotiations with the agents we've got
it moved down to the bottom end but when
I had some concerns at the top embassies
open setting and negations the bar at
the bottom was more logical to go with
the land
understood Thank You councillor bonds I
mean I'm caught up happy to support the
opposition mendacious because as far as
I'm concerned it's mixed or another one
it's isn't in open country so it really
it's against the big hedge I can't see
the concern seems to be the house that
obviously was opposed which has been
approved and now we got the bond which I
can't see a problem on quite a bit it
prefers the obvious is recommended to
confirm councillor Barnes is that
proposal doesn't just to confirm is that
a proposal
yeah yes Thank You councillor carriage
and this is a second marvelous anyone
anyone else wants to take part in the
debate no ok so we'll move to the
recommendation I would also remind you
we do have an additional condition on
our update sheet that restricts the use
to agricultural storage I'm assuming
your proposal and second included that
and your thought process in which case
let's move to the proposal which is to
grant in line with the officers
recommendation and the condition on the
update sheet all those in favor mr.
chairman thank you so the committee
therefore resolves to grant application
1700 8 5 6 ful in line with the
recommendation and the update sheet
fantastic ok let's move to our next
application which is application
reference 1701 435 ful Andrew Watson is
once again that are presenting offsets
so Andrew as soon as you are set up and
ready it is over to you
what well here is an application for a
full permission for the direction of two
dwellings one being the replacement of
the existing existing bungalow with
another and the additional ones make two
eternally old school laying it will
occur site is roughly where the black
spot is on the I'm not plan you can see
there and move it into it the model
spacious say the application for the
bill to pet it's just within the
built-up area which is not shell on that
plan at all the pink round refers to the
conservation area list of buildings I
lighted in red the old school Lane runs
north-south from the top corner sites
they just beyond the first red building
off the main road there it is a private
road say again there over a salad and I
refer scruffy on the site I didn't read
the bungalow which is the big build in
the middle and then they got feels to
select the right outside into the left
and north we have got the existing
development in terms of plans what we
got there the maps from the existing
Moonglow which is about 60 meters by
nine and a half meters roughly with
height to 6.6 and 2.7 to the Eve's class
so it's a four point six meter in terms
of the ridge and 2.4 to these so I got
got it wrong there and there the two
proposed dwellings we have got two lot
single-story we've got rooms in the roof
space but it's been designed to keep it
a little bit lower and that's how the
both guys fit on site in the garden in
terms of fee photographs that stood at
the entrance to the site looking back
into the property you can see the
property just there on the left can be
under the those kind of the trees on the
right hand side are within the garb
it's about forms boundary and the
Gardiners also be armed that's the rear
of the property to the gardens little
bit over grow where the Tim fences on
the right that's the far town tree with
the fields to the right of that that's
the rear of the property and these are
photographs looking down old school Lane
that's looking from with the back to the
property of looking down laying at that
point so you can just see on the right
we've got a couple of bungalows there's
nothing on the left at this point
looking back the other way the property
on the left you see the place that they
are single-story dwellings and say
opened down old school lane we've got a
mixture of houses or bungalows and the
mixture of materials including paint
render and stone and that's the access
to the property so the junction which is
sufficiently wide enough for two
vehicles to pass one way to didn't turn
out the junction and for another car
pulling quite easily without causing any
problems so we have got a recommendation
for approval and there's nothing else -
I'd be updates you fabulous thank you
very much let's move to our first
speaker then which is counsel at
McMillan from Willett parish council
counselor welcome
so you've I've noticed you've been here
for a while so I think you know the
drill the button in the middle we'll
turn the microphone on then to close
otherwise it all starts a muffle you
have three minutes as soon as you're
ready please start we'll give you a 30
second one okay thanks our main concern
is really the fact that this the three
bungalows are on on the plot the one
which is due to be demolished a
significantly lower than any of the
building around and the two proposed
buildings aren't actually dormer
bungalows as it says in the application
actually full fledged
version detached houses there was a
previous plan application which was not
40 metres away for a proposed
bungalow to be converted to file
budgeted house house which was recently
turned down on the grounds that it was
overpowering and height of imposing on
other gardens there in Wilko currently
51 percent of people of retirement age
so we feel it a shame for a bungalow
which a retired couple can move into to
be demolished four to five bedroom detox
houses which frankly won't get does not
need as there are currently five percent
of houses in banco a fortified bedroom
with two occupants and they need to
downsize and I've currently nowhere in
one Karen to downsize to this is just
one of our main major concerns we
understand houses are needed in
Stratford and will encode but not a mile
away those do to be 500 houses built in
bishops and line which will absolutely
an income for keeping the school shop
going and everything else that we just
don't see the need for knocking down a
baton bungalow four to five vacant
houses just as someone it can make some
money that's a thank you very much
casa carriage so thank ballad argument
just when they heard stands up you know
policy-wise do you have any sort of
evidence that he has indeed serving up
or parish plan we currently have a world
cup parish neighbourhood plan which is
in consultation at the moment and our
planning policy is limited in fell only
and I think this is actually limited in
fact demolishing one house to build
- I don't think is technically infill
and we are a numbers wise we did a
planning survey where most people wanted
to - three-bedroom houses and affordable
housing not five four or five bedroom
detached houses there's just not needed
and we'll go
just in sorry kg so who's the carriage
can you make sure you're my friends on
all fair weather any mentions there
wasn't okay thanks Cass there's any
further questions at this point
No thank you very much for your input
and we have no further speakers on this
application so we'll move straight to
technical questions cats the Giants just
one did it
I'm all right in saying that the test
here is that because it's Greenbelt
we've got to be satisfied and it's got
falling one of the exceptions we've got
to be satisfied that the redevelopment
wouldn't have a greater impact on the
openness of the green boat than
otherwise right okay so I'm just I
suppose I just wanted you to help me a
little bit come just bit concern that
we've got volume which is a very you
know significantly larger and height
which is larger and we're replacing two
properties with one how that sort of
stacks up against the it not happen you
know not having a greater impact on the
openness yeah so this is fair argument I
was what I was doing the report and
looking that I was going through all the
figures and crossed my mind trying to
look at his hair I don't think in my
view that there is a much bigger
difference there yes there's a
difference because the two properties
because I think will cuts from those
villages which is now is very limited
what it will allow because of the green
belt and I think this one is one of the
exceptions where it won't be a problem
for the green belt or the openness of it
I'm gonna ask a question if I may the ls
region is it casually three oh gosh
before and and as a result of that how
many houses it need to take how many has
it taken this cut route through - yeah
and so housing requirement of category
remind me not man about no I'm not it's
not my name now we're under the number
as well okay that's helpful thank you
accounts Cara sure yeah just oh can we
have some pictures of the the
surrounding houses as well just to go
over this a surrounded bungalow think so
look down towards them maybe from from
up above and the neighborhood plan issue
nothing about bungalows but definitely
mention of two and three-bedroom houses
which these aren't it's a very good
argument I think everybody around the
table will understand that we do want
bungalows it's even in our our local
plan that we want more bungalows these
are this is a bungalow already so two
bungalows it would be incredibly
desirable have we got a policy hook for
that I feel we should but I don't if
there is one and also what would you
know it obviously doesn't conform with
that with the the neighborhood plan
so what wait does that have in terms of
the neighborhood plans the neighborhood
plan is still under progression so that
has limited weight in terms of the
assessment in relation to the size of
the units that assessment would have
been undertaken at the as an integral
part of the assessment of the
suitability of the site and
appropriateness of this application can
serve answer I don't know whether you
can help but the Parish Council said
there was one very similar next door
refused on side both cameras that
correct on would you do not know yes
there was another application which was
refused on delegate delegate to powers
recently I was aware of acts how to use
the report in preparation of this one so
that they've got other issues with
solicitor building conservation area so
there were different reasons to consider
and refused it as well
the counselors anymore for technical
questions no let's mix it up eight then
who would like to start me off cancer
feeling showed first in cancer Charles
encouraged having expected a site it's a
large site as you can see from that
image I understand the need for small
smaller units but if one was to go for
enough heat small units it wouldn't
wouldn't make the best use of the site
by putting two houses or dorm aha
bungalows in as its described I feel
that it's making the best use of the
site as its the entity I don't like is a
shared drive to the to the two houses
but apart from that I don't see any
objection to it Thank You Council
Chancellor I'm concerned about this
application because we've been quite
strict with other applications where
they've sought to redevelop in the green
boat and we've been quite strict on
making sure that the property that
they're replacing and obviously there's
no difficulty with the principle of
redevelopment here or replacement
dwelling but making sure that it doesn't
have a greater impact and I just I mean
I think yes they are bungalows but it's
stretching it they're very large
properties and it's going to be a very
significant increase in terms of both
volume and height and I just think I
just think for me I just feel it doesn't
quite get over that that threshold of
saying it wouldn't have a greater impact
on the openness of the green boat
because I'm struggling to visualize how
two properties instead of one that leads
to a collective and individual greater
volume and greater height for both of
them I'm struggling out for me
personally to see how that doesn't
infringe on that and how it meets the
test so I'm not completely comfortable
with this I think you can still feel
inclined why'd you turn your microphone
off please
Kancil carriage oh yeah I'm with
counselor Charles on this I think
because it's a location at the edge of
the village I think calling it infill is
stretching it actually I don't think it
is infill because it's coming out it's
written it's within the curtilage but
it's certainly not within the building
line so I think the Greenbelt issue is
valid and I don't think it does fit the
exception which which which in my
opinion doesn't fit the exceptions they
would need very special circumstances
and there aren't any you know if
anything it's it's a negative rather
than the positive if for instance it was
two or even three bungalows perhaps or
or smaller properties which would
obviously be a benefit to weigh against
the negative of harm to the green boat
then I might reconsider it but there is
no benefit to weigh against that so I'd
have to go against offices in this one
and recommend refusal Thank You
councillor bonds yes I can see the
objection to this because that once our
many has it didn't have to be more than
15 or 25 percent it's any bigger
these are substantially bigger but I
think they do fit in the plot if there's
a fart bedroom as they move out of a two
or three-bedroom house to cover that so
you sort of get a small as to replace a
big one I don't think we're refusing
I can't really see a solid reason for
Appeals although I have concern my
microphone is not working properly just
before I go back to the floor so the
feeling I'm getting is this is a great
deal of concern I'll just draw members
to attention to page 44 of the report
cs10 B which suggests states that a
small scale extensions or alterations of
buildings or the replacement of existing
buildings the same use are permitted in
Greenbelt as long as the replacement
building is not materially larger than
one it replaces that materially larger
as key in my thought process and then if
you look two or three paragraphs down
the existing dwellings have a volume of
491 the replacement would have thirteen
hundred and eleven floor space of 215
and the new would have three hundred and
thirty-two so there's one of you bear
that in mind when you're making your
decision making if it helps in your
decision making cancer giants I mean I
think I'd be inclined to propose refusal
on YES on the basis of those specifics
which is it doesn't it doesn't meet the
exception which is that it's not
materially larger because I think I
think actually the evidence therein is
that it's materially larger and I think
that's the sufficient reason for refusal
and I propose it okay we have a voter
cancer carriage the our second that okay
me I was sitting there counselor Crump
you have shown before we moved so please
just oh they're in the enemy team we
actually turn one down it's totally
because we've got concerns we need to
clarify is it was good good but not
quite right so I think were being
consistent because I've got doubts about
this I regarding the size and you know
at page 43 so I think we are being
consistent if we do refuse this because
we're not happy with it and there could
be a better use of the pot in it in the
same way as we said earlier so on happy
to support cancer jars
okay so we have a president second out
I'm going to ask just for clarity on
wording I would suggest
disproportionately larger than the
building it replaces if that's okay with
both our proposal now secondly I would
also want you to consider a material
change in the street scene given the
bungalows next to this this proposal and
whether you think that would be an
appropriate reason for refusal as well
I'm happy for that to be added because I
know I know old school Lane and yeah
there's a certain character there and I
think what we can see is that there is
that sort of because what happens is the
development becomes more diffuse as you
get cut to the edge of the village
boundary and nothing almost building it
up is not particularly in keeping so I I
would entirely agree with that being an
it is a reason okay our second I can
scared you happy with that
okay marvelous in that case I'm Karen
could you just for clarity again feed us
back exactly the two reasons we have
please two reasons and I suggest we roll
that into one reason for refusal there
be a conflict with the green green belt
in that there be the dwellings are
proportionately larger than the
buildings it replaced and therefore in
conflict in terms of the impact on the
openness of the green belt and a second
issue in relation to the character the
impact on the character of the street
scene by virtue of the design and scale
of the buildings okay I'm happy with
that proposed roads are secondaries okay
in that case let's move to the vote so
the recommendation sorry the vote is to
refuse in line with the the reasons we
have just given for those in favor of
refusal of pleasure
four five six chairman buy the game
you're gonna cancel herb answer to
obsession to obsessions okay so the kids
here therefore moves to refuse the
application in line with the reason
given thank you very much
okay members let's let's move on to our
next our next item which is application
reference 1701 four four six ful at
Croft Lane temple graft and presenting
officer is Eleanor bus and as soon as
you are ready you are welcome to get
cracking
Thank You chairman
this application is a retrospective
application for store building the
application site lies to the north sorry
the application site lies to the north
of the village of Temple Grafton as
identified by the black dot the site is
located off Croft Lane and is within the
existing permitted gypsy and traveller
site a public footpath runs
approximately 885 meters away to the
south of the site here we have the site
plan with a location of the store along
the southern boundary of pitch - these
are the elevations of the store which
measures three point three meters high
three point six meters wide and five
point five meters deep and I'll go on to
show some photos here we're standing
within the site looking towards the
store the existing mobile home is cited
to the right and the dayroom
in front of this we are stood further
down the site now looking up towards the
store building which runs parallel to
the southern boundary hedge standing at
the top of the site with the approved
pictures in front of us the store is
located where the arrow is pointing in
the photo in between the mobile home and
the dayroom
there are no updates to the application
chairman the recommendation is to grant
the application subject to the
conditions set out in page 57 of the
agenda fabulous thank you very much oh
no okay let's move to straight away to
our first speaker caster Keyes welcome
back
he's got this one that's fine okay so
you know the drill three minutes as soon
as you're ready get cracking and we will
give you a 30-second warning chairman
thank you she's a bit like Groundhog Day
we're talking here about sight which is
150 yards from the one we just spoken
about but so many of the points I made
previously are relevant to this as well
and we'll make them again if you wish me
to otherwise I'll skip I have to say
when this one came in it was a
disappointment to the parish council
that a mere three weeks after the
applicant had received permission on
that site that a building went up
without permission and we've struggled
with that a little bit and judging by
the design of it to us it doesn't look
much like a store building it certainly
doesn't look very secure and we are
concerned about proliferation and over
development of this site frankly it
looks more like a domestic annex and I
think it would be extraordinary if this
were the last application we were to see
on this site I think for the reasons I
said before we are trying to be
consistent in Temple Grafton and that's
why we have objected to this one thing I
didn't mention before was that we are
quite close to becoming a local service
village and our residents tell us in
terms of the threshold of dwellings and
our resident says they don't want to be
a local service village so we are trying
to manage that and define where we might
have
development of where we don't want
development Croft Lane is in the special
landscape area a big fuss was made about
the landscape harm at the appeal sadly
the inspector didn't share the view of
the majority certainly in the village
that this is on an even higher portion
of ground and the previous application
and it is very visible from various
quarters we are concerned as I say that
this site will just get more and more
crowded and if you look at it from the
east and the Northeast
it is rather a blot on the landscape
thank you and in conclusion I would just
say that that's like being over
developed sets a really bad precedent in
the district and certainly for this
particular site thank you
well thank you very much thank Anse the
keys and members any questions no Marvis
okay thank you very much we'll move to
our second speaker in that case which is
our applicant mr. Ronnie Smith welcome
now you know the drill having observes a
number of applications so far so as soon
as you only got three minutes I'll give
you a 30 second one as soon as you're
comfortable exchange stop look someone's
not gonna go and live in there I came to
the keys expecting and we put another
bunch in there as a
in the village recently my friend my
neighbor he had burglars take these
tools I just thought it would be an idea
to put the tools in a safekeeping and I
think it's a lot of fuss for nothing
it's just a [ __ ] never look here I don't
why do you've still got a minute
two minutes in fact to speak if you want
to but I mean if that's if you I think
you've said what you need to say that's
a straight convey Thank You members to
how many questions kasib ants in the
middle of the site is it if you go down
to fuels in look forward okay excellent
was that an intubation or just having a
scratch okay members unless we have any
other unless you have any other
questions thank you very much Council
bonds if you're going to answer
questions please can you allow the
person to answer next time rather than
answering for them as well it will help
speed things up a little bit okay so our
next speaker is councillor Adams cancer
Adams come forward with whose thank you
it's against Holmes you have five
minutes we'll give you a 30-second
warning whenever you're ready
Marvis thank you very much members any
questions no okay thank you very much
we'll move them to our technical
questions anyone have a technical
question and it is a timber building
it's not as I think it says store store
should have gone suspect savers council
feeling okay
any other questions for technical
responses no okay let's move to debate
in that case counselor Giles okay I do
sympathize with the parish wanting to
make sure that this site stays open
because it looks great it's well
maintained and I understand the desire
to want to keep it that way I think when
the applicant says it's just a shed it's
a very very good summary of the
application and in fact the port
consider the fact that a shed is is
proposed or storage rather than having
things out and about and scattered
around the site not just the security
aspect that's obviously going to
contribute to keeping it in a nice and
tidy sight I do accept the point that
it's not ideal that it's retrospective
because that deprives the
opportunity for comment to have been
passed on any aspect of it but since
it's such a minor building I think in
this case I accept the recommendation of
the officer would propose grant thank
you as about suffice with clarity on
that counts the carriage yes sir I will
second that again marvelous thank you I
just gonna throw my tea pennyworth in at
the end of the day as you say it is a
shared committee development rights have
gone from this site I think this
otherwise would have been allowed and
permitted development right it's were
only here because that's not available
okay so we have pros that we have a
seconder and let's move so the proposal
is to grant in line with the officers
recommendation please can I have a show
of hands for support unanimous chair
marvelous okay so in that case committee
resolves to grant application 1701 446
ful in line with officers recommendation
so to our next application which is
application number 1701 9:00 to 8:00 ful
our presenting opposite is once again
and on the bus so whenever you're ready
over to you
Thank You chairman this application is a
full application for the erection of a
new dwelling and garage along with the
widening of the existing access the
application site lies to the northern
part of the village of town with an
Arden identified by the black dot the
site is located on doctor's Hill with
the conservation area boundary running
to the west of the site as shown by the
pink line on the plan
there are several listed buildings near
to the site most notably the grade 2
listed doctor's house which is opposite
the site and shaded in red on the plan
this is an aerial view of the
application site which is outlined in
red here we have the existing site plan
on the left and the proposed site plan
on the right this clearly shows the
footprint of the proposed dwelling and
its relationship with the surrounding
properties this plan shows the layout of
the proposed dwelling in more detail
with the location of the access onto
doctor's Hill the garage is to be
located to the right of the dwelling
with a parking and turning area in front
of the house and to the left but first
floor three bedrooms are to be provided
these are the proposed front and rear
elevations of the dwelling it is to be
constructed constructed of Arden red
brick with a plain clay tiled roof these
are the proposed side elevations of the
dwelling the sections show the outline
of the grade 2 listed doctor's house
which is opposite the site we now have
some photos here we're standing on
doctor's Hill with the application site
in front of us behind the gate in
fencing standing further up doctors here
we have the application site on the
right-hand side with number 1 doctor's
Hill adjacent to it we're looking at the
grade 2 listed doctor's house which is
situated opposite the application site
members will notice elevated position
and status from the road
stood in the application site now we
have the listed doctor's house directly
in front of us and the side wall of the
neighboring property to the left of the
photo the proposed dwelling will be
sited on the land in front again
standing on doctor's Hill we have the
application site on the right and
doctors house on the left of the photo
this photo is taken looking up towards
the application site which is behind the
trees and vegetation the doctor's house
is just about visible to the right of
the photo there are no updates to the
application German the recommendation is
to refuse the application the reason set
out on pages 72 to 73 of the agenda
fantastic thank you Anna okay our first
speaker is councillor Shepherd from
Thomas nard and parish council cancer
shepherd please come forward
good evening and welcome you know the
drill by now three minutes I'll give you
a 30 second warning as soon as you're
comfortable ready you may start good
evening
I'm graduated fourth statement in
support Sorry Sorry apologies I'm here
to read a short statement in support of
Timothy Arden parish councils objections
that proposed development the parish
council accepts that a new design and is
an improvement on the proposal
previously submitted in terms of the
design and use of vernacular materials
however the site is on the cusp of the
conservation area and the process
development would still have an adverse
effect on the historic character of the
village the street scene and the view
into the conservation area this is a
sensitive site which provides a visual
break between the horan historic part
the village and later development to the
south the street scene is characterized
by a house front
and all high hedges close to all on the
back half of the pavement whilst the
north of the later developments which
dates in the mid 20th century is set
well back from the road with sizeable
front gardens and wide grass verges to
preserve this distinction the proposed
development should be set in line with
the later development the proposal would
also have a negative impact on the
setting of the doctor's house for the
reason set out and the offices report
this would be ameliorated by the
proposed development being sent back on
the plot the reason the proposal is set
forward presumably is because of the
constraints of the site and its shape in
conclusion no public benefits exist to
outweigh the harm that this development
would caused to the historic character
of the village and the parish council of
therefore maintains its objection to the
proposal and respectfully request that
you support the officers recommendation
to refuse thank you
fantastic thank you very much members do
we have any questions no in that case
thank you very much we'll move to our
next speaker who's our agent Julia day
please come down and while you're
walking we do only have yourself
registered speak Julia so there will it
be you doing all the speaking and we've
got a dis gentleman from our support
he's welcome to sit and if we have any
specific questions but we've got you
registered speak so three minutes is
allocated to you that's fine
thank you so as soon as you're ready
you've got three minutes I'll give you
30 second one
that's the main concerns raised by the
officer and concerned I can find to
Heritage issues and the street scene and
the position on the plot so I'm going to
concentrate just on those matters with
regard to the conservation area the
application site has been described in
the offices reports as an important
green gap or an in unimportant open
space
it is neither it's a private garden land
and it's adjacent to and I outside the
conservation area this conservation area
was designated as far as I'm aware in
1990 1969 sorry and amended with
alterations in 1994 this includes sorry
the conservation area as it is includes
a large swathe of undeveloped land in
particular to the west of the village I
don't know whether you're able to show
the conservation boundaries again that
would be helpful here is if the
application site contributes so greatly
to the Heritage character of the area
and if the council had wished to
exercise greater planning control then
it would have already been included in
the conservation area but it is not
additionally the council has not imposed
any article for directions to remove
permitted development rights this means
certain buildings may be constructed on
the application site using PD rights
without needing specifically an approval
from the council as decision-makers it's
a quite appropriate for you to take into
account the relative impacts of what may
be developed here as PD against the
perceived impact of the house and garage
with regard to the plot character of the
street senior officers prayer
preferences for a back of pavement
dwelling but the position on the plot
has been carefully chosen to reflect the
juxtaposition between the historic core
of the village where a pack of bait of
both back of pavement dominates and a
more modern houses to the north
it's further back to the plots
conversely the parish council suggests
it would be better pushed back into the
plot but this would impact on the minis
immunities of day of the day lights and
residents of their houses either side so
we feel this is not a realistic option
the regardlessly building setting the
new building would be set back from the
carriageway and its closest point about
seven seventeen point seven meters or 58
feet from the listed doctor's house the
road here bends from either approach and
the side views of the listed building
would not be compromised due to the
setback of the proposed house and the
front view of the Lister building will
not change doctors house is great to
list a building it does not stand in
Spain splendid rural isolation with
nothing around it it's surrounded by
development both within and adjacent to
its own curtilage I'm very sorry but
your time has expired
members to see if they have any
questions no shouting how many cars will
the garage take and is there enough room
to keep people off the street because
[Music]
the design has been in in in standard if
you like the the garage is realistically
going to accommodate one one standard
size car with a turning area to the
front as well as the parking area okay
thank you I would say that the county
council after we submitted further plans
we through their original objection
thank you murmurs any further questions
no in that case thank you very much okay
thank you
so next speakers counts that atkinson
freshman china an agent go
okay.we I don't think we've got time to
go into that now so you have five
minutes counsel Atkinson yes I don't
need to know you have five minutes
counselor ikenson
whenever you're ready good evening
members and officers on page 65 of the
committee report it confirms the site is
within the built-up area of the village
and is therefore a sustainable location
MPP F does tell us that there is a
presumption in favor of sustainable
development also on page 66 you tell
that the site is infill no harm exists
to the openness of the Greenbelt and the
proposal is a development that is not
inappropriate the issue whether or not
the setting of a listed building on the
other side of the road is affected
although if openness is preserved and
the development is a highway depth away
it is difficult to comprehend what
adverse impact exists upon the listed
building particularly as it remains
dominant and does not have its views
disadvantaged there have been a number
of successful appeals where a similar
influence prevailed
actually one was for three houses within
term with an Arden at doctor's close
which within a minutes walk of this a
particular site the notice of decision
read rather similar you know the local
permanent Authority any development of
this site would result in substantial
harm to the designated heritage assets
namely to the setting the Conservation
Area and the setting of the nearby grade
2 listed buildings plural not one now
the inspector withheld the appeal and in
his sort of
opinion the special-interest of the
listed buildings would not be materially
affected by the development and their
significance would not be harmed that I
believe would be exactly the same for
doctor's house not only that but
throughout the district a number of
applications for a new development close
to and adjacent to listed buildings have
come forward with very much similar
expressions by an inspector Penny
Compton is one on Western on Haven is
another where exactly the same points
are brought out now not only did the
inspector support the application but he
awarded costs against the District
Council the the recommendation to refuse
does not highlight the points in cs8
which favor the application no risks
exists to the listed building working
with the highway authority was not
detracted from the historical value of
the street scene and the distinctive
character of the village is unaffected
section 134 of the NPP F mentioned
security securing optimum use of a site
the body of the report we are told the
development is not inappropriate which i
think means securing optimum use the
setback statement is odd that is a
setback of the properties because if you
look at appendix one you will see that
is what they principally are they are
set back from the road and the pavement
actually the building here is been
created to be in line with an extension
which went to number one doctors closed
its neighbor it fits in very well and in
my opinion anyone visiting the proposed
site will confirm it does not contribute
in its current state to the dignity of
the area the application in my opinion
remedies that the development will I
believe enhance the setting and without
disadvantage to the listed building
bearing in mind the comments I've made
about Appeals
I hope members will reverse with the
recommendation Thank You chairman Thank
You councillor members do we have any
questions for cancer Atkinson no
marvelous thank you very much thank you
so it's moved to our next stage which is
technical questions any technical
questions cancer carriage yes but um
various examples they're given by Count
Dracula some of Appeal decisions very
similar ones a few hundred yards away
can you comment on that because it does
seem very relevant I'm not aware of the
specific details of the appeal decisions
but the doctors close one I believe I've
got it on this plan here which is this
area here
if it helps thank you thank you can
Sakhalin and if it helps I remind
members that we are looking at each
individual application on its own
individual merits so watched yes there
have been decisions made on other sites
it's not this site this site we're
looking at tonight in regards to that
doctor's clothes that peel it may be
that there as counsel Rich's pointed out
different circumstances the proximity of
the listed buildings appear to be much
further away and okay listed buildings
are listed for their own special
qualities that are unique to that
particular building that may be
different for other building listed
buildings okay any further technical
questions and before I come to you can't
smell cancer I can sing you need please
turn off your microphone someone please
do
it does it causes a problem with our
broadcast Thank You councillor bonds the
distance between the new build and the
listed building is because the building
and I have a separation of about 17
meters from the front of the listed
doctor's house to the front of the and
proposed dwelling okay any further
questions for clarity or technical input
nope marvelous let's move to debate
council autumn Thank You chairman this
is a it's quite a difficult one but and
sort of thinking that this strikes me as
a just the classic infill site and I
don't see any problem with the
positioning of the building within that
infill site so the point is is whether
this new building which is obviously
required in town with an ardent and does
have such an effect on the heritage
asset of the doctor's house which is 17
18 meters opposite looking at what is on
the sort of southern side of this site
and the northern side of this site these
these buildings are hardly any
architectural merits are either and I
just think that this development seems
to improve the street scene so I would
in this case be very happy to to support
the applicant and ago against the
officers recommendation and I would
propose that if I could find a second
I'd be grateful thank you out councillor
barn so first then councillor Jarl
sandcastle-building my concern really is
that it should be in line it's basically
the old the the after the war buildings
if you want to put it that way as far as
I'm concerned I could support of the if
it was back in the site at the moment I
understand resistance against the listed
building so I'm going with the opposite
recommendation but all I'm saying is
that the
should be along with the other buildings
and they've all then would be alright
the existing buildings it will be okay
but at the moment it is Thank You
counsel Charles Council Orton's argument
seems to be the great two listed
building which is a fantastic building
and it is really one of the nicest
medium-sized listed buildings I've seen
in the district I think it's wonderful
Castle Norton's argument seems to be
well it's surrounded by Phyllis Phyllis
Zdenek disappointing building so let's
just carry on no I I think that the
argument on page 67 and 68 of the report
is extremely compelling and particularly
the paragraph which doesn't just talk
about the importance and history of this
building but then it's also what carries
on into the along that road into the
historic core and where it says that the
garden to the north of the doctor's
house and on the opposite side of the
lane provides a valuable vestige of the
historic pattern and rural field setting
the green wedge also creates a buffer
between a uniform modern and historic
development and helping to amplify the
experience of entering historic core in
other words there's been some really
unhelpful undesirable building so it's
itself I don't know whichever direction
of that building there is a bit of a gap
and a bit of a breathing space so that
you're able to come in and appreciate
that really as an entranceway to the
conservation area in historic core and
then it goes on obviously to talk about
the significance of that building and
maintaining the open space around it so
you have and not just an imprint
appreciation of that that buildings
historical and architectural importance
but also it's it gives you an idea of
its history in terms of its social
standing so I think this is a the
conservation officer and the officer
have worked really hard to try to convey
to us what is important about this area
and what we're trying to do in
respecting the conservation and heritage
assets and I find it a very well argued
report and I would be supporting that
recommendation to refuse this thank you
cancer feeling
I'd like to go along with counselor
Lawton it is in fill any concern I've
got having been there at the time of the
school was coming out was just a shared
volume of traffic and trying to get up
and down the street was pretty
horrendous
and therefore I'm concerned there isn't
enough car parking space there I think
if you push the house back to roquette
it in line with the houses to the north
it will get very tight with it looked
from the image that we've had it's a
very tight squeeze at the back and so I
will go along with with councillor
Norton and would like to do granted is
that a seconding of council Hortons
proposal yes thank you
hang on hang on Council bonds hang on
Santa council bonds counselor carriage
for its own that first will come to you
in a second in the middle yeah I'm
actually going to go with with the
officers because it's a recommendation
of of our officers because we are
enjoying it too because they are very
strongly heritage assets and that's what
it is yes we all agree it could be an
infill site and all that but it's the
heritage argument we've got to listen to
I am concerned about what I've heard
about a number of Appeal decisions
recently in the district on heritage
grounds so you know outside of this this
committee are I think maybe we can look
into that perhaps of some kind of
workshop or or training session but in
this occasion I'm gonna have to go with
our offices recommendation Thank You
councillor Ponce you were trying to say
something I was just going to say that
obviously happy tips the second one of
the proposals to go along with the
opposite of a commendation that's all
just just so okay so just so we're clear
we did have a proposal from counsel
autumn to go against our folks officers
recommendation first and that's been
seconded I don't believe I had a
proposal but I might be mistaken cancer
Jones I'm looking you for that I do want
to make that proposal but I didn't know
whether I had to make it after we'd
heard that you're welcome to do it
whenever you like I'm sorry I do make a
proposal to refuse the application in
accordance with the officers report
thank you and counselor bonds I assume
that from okay so so what we are what
we'll do first is take our first
proposal so the first proposal was to
grant permission can I have a show of
hands please in support of granting to
chairman and against fixture so I'm
afraid that does fall flat our second
proposal is to refuse in line with the
officers recommendation if I could
please have a show of hands to refuse
six Jen and those against two can okay
thank you so the committee therefore has
resolved to refuse application 1701 nine
to eight ful in line with the officers
recommendation okay we will now move to
our final piece of business tonight
which is an application up in 1701 736
ful our presenting officer is Andrew
what he as soon as he is sat down and
ready to speak he will get cracking
hopefully it's over to you Andrew
Thank You chair right what we're in
front of us now is an application for a
full plant admission for us a two-story
side extension with loft conversion and
remodeling with a principal elevation
facing so absolutely fields one for
three Ludington real stafford you can
see the site result cakes noted there by
the red black spot the application site
is in the residential part of Ludington
road without wheels on the opposite side
and there are other residential
properties to either side that aerial
photograph and say you can see the
fields on the north and the residential
property the side of the site Ludington
Rio Grande Southwest to Northeast and
the dwelling is set proximate 10 metres
back from the road now what a planter
and the existing elevations and so note
the rail elevation we've got a modern
design extension that was on erector on
committees of urban rights it's the
picture the bottom left-hand corner now
what's a planter in the proposed
elevations the principal the front
elevation is the top left-hand corner
its remodeled toggle 1 & 2 1 &
sacrificed a second-story balcony the
external facing materials includes paint
random brickwork
with a flat roof the height of the light
of which is about the ridge of the
existing dwelling Dover to add artist's
impression
the materials are shown there as well
I've still got the existing floor plans
rose floor plans and a couple of
the top left and caranas the front of
the property until it start right ankle
on the bottom left is one with the
expansion as mentioned that is that was
a record of PD rights and other
properties we were opposite the site on
top left hand corner put the torah
button up and down the roadway and the
recommendation is one put forward of
refusal and there's only an update from
council of arms on the update she
fantastic thank you very much let's move
to our first speaker which is our
applicant mr. Payne mr. Payne would you
like to come forward please
welcome thank you for your patience
sitting through our last I think seven
items we've been through so you
obviously know the drill three minutes
I'll give you a 30-second warning soon
as you're comfortable ready you may
begin
good evening it is a 1947 post-war
family house sunny field trying to drag
it into the 21st century diploma at 2017
modern family home loans and village
design statement a s10 core strategy
sustainable future development by
redevelopment of existing plots 90% of
the officers report supports this
application there's just one element
which needs to the dormer policy cs20 of
a course structure requires alterations
modifications to existing dwellings with
appropriate scale and subservient to the
existing buildings taking into account
the site location where appropriate
requiring any extension be subservient
it's important when the existing
dwelling has some architectural merit
was a uniformed character of a property
within a locality that should be
retained this is not the case in respect
of sunny fields the properties over
seventy years old has no architectural
features of interest or merit he's an
uninspiring house simple in design does
not refer collectively the scale will
design more modern of properties along
that
in row further there's an eclectic mix
of properties along Ludington Road that
has evolved that is acknowledged in by
the case off the roof extension and this
application has therefore been
deliberately designed not to be
subservient in order to design our
dwelling at high architectural quality
that has prominence in the street scene
and enhanced as a character of Ludington
Road in in accordance with policy cs9 of
course strategy the flat element of the
roof will not be visible from the front
of a property and will only be glimpsed
at an oblique angle from the West the
extent to which the roof extension and
balcony to extend beyond the front
elevation is not going to be noticed
when the street scene the first floor
balcony respects the garage line the
second floor respects the roofline in
summary the proposal development will
transfer one low quality poorly designed
building into an attractive modern
design to enhance the character of the
locality on the appearance the area
early consultation with neighbors and
parish results in full parish neighbor
and ward support for this application
urge the committee to endorse a
significant EPC upgrade solar PV thermal
ground source heat pump charging point
for an Eevee rainwater harvesting an
extensive reefs of materials of site
such as it has not been one skip on site
through the development
please note Elizabeth's house has a flat
roof door 30 second thank you
that is the gist of what I wanted to say
thank you very much aunt lemons - how
many questions no in that case thank you
very much once again thank you for your
patience and castle bonds you our next
speaker please would you make your way
through the chair you know the drill you
have one minute
five minutes 30 second one I could use
one word but I won't - good
this if you look at the map in your
battery or you know the agenda you will
see that this Ludington road is the
number of 197 houses all together and
i-131 the other week you opposed an
application which was up for grant and
which the people just stopped the road
not dissimilar to this but we in the
respective have extended an old house
which this is this is exactly it haven't
been chances it was built and this
particular application he refused and
the inspector totally supported you and
in his report he said this presumed
urban sprawl in the open countryside
otherwise all the way along this road
was either open countryside at one side
or the river on the other down the
bottom there's a total mix of different
types of properties everybody's doing
their own thing if you want to put it
that way there was a house not
dissimilar to this about 20 doors down
and there's one near a town now I spoke
to the neighbors they were concerned
about the footings on his ground or not
his ground they came to an agreement
that they could you know with a
solicitor do what they wanted to do
everybody's happy the parish council
lady unfortunately has got a 60th
birthday that I said she couldn't come
but as you can see the pile council
support is in line with the parish plan
I appreciate it's a little bit different
it's environmentally friendly this house
if you
the reason the picture is hasn't been
touched in 70 years I hope that you were
fully supported with the appropriate
conditions and I don't think there's any
need for me to go on anymore
I've looked at it once I looked at it
again on my bike went along the road and
as you can see they have these in the
back gardens up against the river all
over it's an urban sprawl in the
countryside and we support this
application Thank You councillor two
minutes so I was quick makes a change
members do we have any questions for
councillor Vance no questions okay
council thank you very much so any
questions councillor Giants can see ours
can you put your microphone on please
could we just have the photos and photos
back house currently the front oh yeah
yeah that previous one slide the
photographic slide 9 I think yeah yeah
okay so just so I understand that visual
of the principle elevation is what's at
the back is what's going to be at the
back that's the rear elevation yeah the
top left-hand corner is the front
elevation which is staying one which is
where the accent would be that's been
remodel as fairly as for the previous
plan which is so that's going to be the
front that will be front elevation yes
right sorry
yeah okay okay counselor feeling it's
very difficult to see from that block of
four pictures what the neighboring
houses on either side looked like
they're very conventional and this is
gonna rather stick out isn't it and my
question is is it out of keeping with
the street scene in the road I guess
that's for your judgement the officer
has a recommendation forward with that
information in in his opinion as for
your judgment sadly we can't really see
what how does it look like
counselor combo the ward member in his
short eloquent speech did actually say
that this road was full of different
types and designs I think exact words
were an eclectic mix do we have any
further questions for technical no if we
move into debate then please cancel Josh
go first in councilor carriage Catholic
so thank you on the pro seven analysis
to be one sentence which is the
objection to this which has been alluded
to dominant presence which could not be
considered sensitive to the existing
bill form I think that's pretty much it
and in a way I agree will be dominant
and and it won't be necessarily
sensitive to the neighboring buildings
it won't be certainly they are much more
traditional all the way along it's quite
a long stretch of houses before you get
to anything as modern looking as this so
it will stand out I think the design is
a really really nice way to turn this
obviously old and shut the building into
something really quite impressive and
stunning and so will stand out and I
think that's such a positive thing
actually that I would go against the the
offices I can understand why you might
want to agree with the officer because I
do but I think it's done so well that
it's actually a positive thing and and
it is a personal judgment I think we all
have to make on this because that that
is the essence of the decision before we
move on is that a proposal it is thank
you against a chance I mean I think I
would imagine committees sort of agreed
some sort of improvement so this is is
positive and and actually I'm and and
there are examples with in Ludington of
although further not on this part of
Reddington Road of modern design and
it's not a design which inherently
offends me I think that there's many
nice aspects I I am just a little bit
concerned because that it is just it
just slightly tips over that line of
being just a little bit too bold because
a long Ludington Road I mean actually
the property along there all of it none
of it is of huge architectural
significance but when we look at what's
said on pace every time I mean it's true
that pretty much everywhere along there
is a traditional paged roof and then
what we're going to introduce in it's a
very
non-stretch is a long long road and
pretty much I think almost everything
along there is pitched roof and yes
there's different styles but all within
a similar type so this is going to he's
going to really stand out and it's going
to be a real statement and I just
bearing in mind that yes the other side
of the road is open countryside and I'm
just concerned that it just I mean I'm
not necessary post something that stands
out a little bit but I just think it
tips over the line and I think I think
for me just on balance what's said here
is that it would become a dominant
presence the flat roof of the extension
would contrast visually with the
existing traditional pitched roof over
the property and I think on along the
street scene as well I think the timber
cladding I think that is a good point as
well I mean there are no examples of
timber cladding really or none of the
noticeable down there so I think I'm
just on fine balance I think I would be
going with the offices recommendation on
this Thank You councillor Crump on this
one
Irish Council support pretty no
objections one letter support the warden
member supports so yeah I'm happy to
support the carriage and second is
proposal marvelous thank you very much
so we have a proposal and a seconder so
they want to have anything else to say
before we move to that no okay so the
proposal is to grant a grant plank
permission
the reason okay cancer couch I've said
the reason I was going to get into the
proposal the first thought the question
is is the quality of the design if
counsel Crump would agree with that
that's fine okay so we have a reason I'm
going to assume that we have standard
conditions are only and are there any
additional conditions you want to add no
I think these would be standard
conditions sure okay to health proposal
we have standard conditions I have a
reason to go against their
recommendation so could I please have a
show of hands for those in support of
granting planning permission on this
site three chairmen and those against
three chairmen and abstentions one
chairman he would leave it to this one
morning yes I am going to stick with my
original thought process which is to
refuse I don't think I need to have
reasons for it but I do think this is
massively out of keeping in that street
scene there are similar houses on a
different part of Ludington I haven't
seen them here and I think it would be
very much out of character so I am going
to refuse that recommendation we're
going against the recommendation correct
my first rodeo okay so we have I would
only cusp of a proposal I think from
cancer John so I'm going to ask her to
make a proposal if she has one yes I
would propose to refuse the application
in accordance with the officers report
thank you can I seek a seconder please
in that case I will second that and as
Eric particularly feel strongly about
second million degrees
okay so he'll approach that we have
second dare to refuse in line with the
officers recommendation and in the
report can I have a show of hands please
to refuse the application
three chairmen and against its refusal
creature extensions counselor filling
okay
so again we're gonna stick to my
original decision which is to refuse a
refute prior permission so the committee
therefore resolves to refused my
permission on application 1701 seven
three six f you are that to therefore
concludes our business night so ladies
and gentlemen members thank you very
much for your input we'll see you next
time